c'est à vous en faire
je m'appelle râle et je suis un méchant
vous devriez pas frapper un binoclard
des fois où vous avez frappé un
binoclard alors ça c'est fait bien jouer
la destination de tous les jeux
attention c'est pas facile d'aimer son
travail quand personne ne vous aime pour
ce que vous faites
la compagnie tout va bien tu es méchant
mais cela ne veut pas forcément dire que
tu es méchant
oui mes cheveux plus être un méchant
bras
tout va changer maintenant alpes est
allé dans un autre je vous ferai d'un
jeu à l'ordre tu n'as pas le droit de
saboter le programme à la consule de
survie sugar rush pourquoi pas un
centime monstrueusement grotte je sais
pas et toi pourquoi tu simmons
heureusement cassante allemand a
abandonné son jeu oui c'est lui qui
casse tout notre jeu était réglé on va
nous débrancher pour de bon il faut
réparer ça et j'ai besoin de fonds m g
près
tu es une gagnant gagnant et puis tu es
adorable et puis c'est un top de ta
maman soit fière de toi j'ai piloté avec
son spatial
la marchande
vous essayez
j'ai fait des progrès oui tu as failli
faire péter toute la montagne c'est un
bon ta place